you were cast in Quentin Tarantino's
upcoming film that everyone's extremely
excited about once upon a time in
Hollywood
you could cast this film I know you're a
huge Tarantino fanatic then you he's got
bad days yeah whatever it's like I know
how exciting that was for you and I
remembered how you know once you were
done with the film and I thought I
haven't had a lot of chance to talk to
you since then what was it like you got
to work with Brad Pitt what was that
like first of all the rate from the jump
the whole thing was it was a dream come
true and the the read-through showing up
I showed up early and I get there and
I'm early my electric car and the other
the only person who arrived just before
me and I guess was Brad Pitt only he
arrived on a chopper and I kind of
thought in your electrified Kia
I kind of thought yeah I was like look
at us both of us no assistance no
entourage we just showed up earlier I
got the battery upper thing and you got
the room but otherwise were like this I
told my wife that guy he's as cool as it
gets and I've said to my wife I told you
that I said you know i-i've always found
I'd never leave my wife for another
woman but there's a chance I might leave
her for Brad she would have to
understand yeah yeah yeah thing where
you you see men all the time then and
then you see Brad Pitt you go oh I get
it I get why I get why people women
don't want to be with that man that's an
incredibly good-looking guy do you think
this interview could get more gay like
just the two of us you think there's
talk I think there's three ways it could
get more game there's a
[Applause]
okay no Conan I will never say what
three and no we're not going to do it